you have to figure out how your job
directly ties to revenue in the business
and if you don't know ask and then once
you understand how you directly tie to
money then drive towards that every
position in the business makes the
business more money even if you're like
I'm a Frontline customer service rep
it's like okay well how do you like if I
had to ask that person like how do you
make the business money the answer is if
I do a good job people will come back
and buy again if I do a good job we'll
have a lower percentage of people who
will refund if I do a good job the
business will be able to command higher
prices off of Word of Mouth in the
future well then if those are the things
that drive Revenue then I'm going to try
and focus on those things and then you
can ask your boss and this is a great
question is what would it take for me to
make this it's not saying I need to make
that it's just asking them to solve the
problem like what would it take for me
to earn that and then they can give you
an objective metric now your boss might
not be high enough and then you say cool
can you ask the person above you by
doing it that way you're also being
clear like I want to make the business
more money and in doing so I would like
a small percentage of the increase that
I'm able to bring what would it take